This lecture is about the feedback in
the language modeling approach.
In this lecture we will continue the
discussion of feedback in text
retrieval.
In particular, we're going to talk
about the feedback in language modeling
approaches.
So we derive the query likelihood
ranking function by making various
assumptions.
As a basic retrieval function, that
formula of those formulas worked well,
but if we think about the feedback
information, it's a little bit of
awkward to use query like hold too.
Perform feedback because a lot of times
the feedback information is additional
information about the query.
But we assume that the query is
generated by assembling words from a
language model in the query likelihood
method.
It's kind of a natural to sample words
that form feedback documents as a
result, then researchers proposed a way
to generalize query like hold function
and it's called a callback labeler
divergance retrieval model.
And this model is actually going to
make the query likelihood retrieval
function much closer to vector space
model.
Yet, this form of the language model
can be regarded as a generalization of
query like hold in the sense that it
can cover query likelihood as a special
case.
And in this case, then, feedback can be
achieved through simple query model
estimation or updating.
This is very similar to Rock Hill which
updates the query vector.
So let's see.
What is this care?
Divergent switchable model?
So on the top, what you see is a query
like hold.
Retrieval function right this one.
And then kill diversions or also called
cross entropy.
Whichever model is basically to
generalize.
The frequency part here.
Into a language model.
So basically it's the difference.
Given by the probabilistic model here
to characterize what the user is
looking for versus the count of query
words there.
And this difference allows us to plug
in various different ways to estimate
this, so this can be estimated in many
different ways, including using
feedback information.
Now this is called a care divergens
becausw.
This can be interpreted as measuring
the care divergent of two
distributions.
One is the query model denoted by this
distribution.
One is talking the language model.
Here smoothly with collection language
model, of course an.
We're not going to talk about the
detail of and then find it in some
references.
It's also called a cross entropy,
because in effect we can ignore some
terms in the care divergent function
and we will end up having actually
cross entropy that both our terms in
information theory.
But anyway for.
Our purpose here you can just receive
the two formulas look almost identical,
except that here we have a probability
of award given by a query language
model.
All this.
And here the sum is over all the words
that are in the document and also with
the non zero probability for the query
model.
So it's kind of again a generalization
of some overall the match query words.
Now you can also easy to see we can
recover the query like hold retrieval
function by simply setting this query
model to the relative frequency of
award in the query.
This is very easy to see once you plug
this into.
Here you can eliminate this query
Lance.
That's a constant and then you get
exactly like that.
So you can see the equivalence.
And that's also why this care divergent
model can be regarded as a
generalization of query, like whole
because we can cover query like Rd as a
special case.
But it would also allow such rule much
more than that.
So this is how we can use the care
divergent model to them the feedback
the picture shows that we first
estimate the document language model.
Then we estimate the query name model
and we compute the KL diversions, as is
often denoted by AD here.
But this basically means this is
exactly like a vector space model
'cause we computer vector for the
document the computer, another vector
for the query and then we compute the
distance only that these vectors are of
special forms their probability
distributions.
And then we got the results and we can
find some feedback documents.
Let's assume they are most inactive.
Sorry, mostly positive documents,
although we could also consider both
kinds of documents.
So what we could do is like in rock
you'll ever know computer another
language model, coder feedback,
language model here.
Again, this is going to be another
vector, just like a computing central
about the in Rock Hill.
And then this model can be combined
with the original query model.
Using a linear interpolation.
And this would then give us a update
model just like again in Rock Hill.
So here we can see the parameter Alpha
can control the amount of feedback if
it's set to 0, then it says here
there's no feedback after set to one,
we got 4 feedback.
If we ignore the original query and
this is generally not desirable, right?
So this unless you are absolutely sure
you have seen a lot of relevant
documents and the query terms are not
important.
So of course the main question here is
how do you compute this single F?
This is the big question here, and once
you can do that, the rest is easy.
So here we will talk about one of the
approaches and there are many
approaches.
Of course this approach is based on
generated model.
And I'm going to show you how it works.
This is the user generated mixable.
So this picture shows that we have this
model.
Here.
The feedback model that we want to
estimate.
And will the basis is the feedback
documents.
Let's say we are observing the positive
These are the click the documents by
users or relevant documents judged by
users or simply top ranked blocking
that we assume to be relevant.
Now imagine how we can compute the
centroid for these documents by using
language Model 1.
Approach is simply to assume these
documents are generated from this
language model as we did before.
What we could do is do just normalize
the word frequency here and then we got
this world distribution.
Now the question is whether this
distribution is good for feedback.
But you can imagine.
The top ranked the world would be what?
What do you think?
Those words would be common words,
right?
As we always see in a language model,
the top ranked words are actually
common words like the etc.
So it's not very good for feedback
because we would be adding a lot of
such words to our query when we
interpret this with the original query
model.
So this is not good.
So when it do something in particular
will are trying to get rid of those
common words and we are we have seen
actually one way to do that by using
background language model.
In the case of learning the
associations with words, words that are
related to the water computer.
We could do that and there will be
another way to do this, but here we are
going to talk about another approach
which is more principled approach.
In this case, we're going to state,
well, you said that there are common
words here in this.
These documents that should not belong
to this topic model, right?
So now what we can do is to assume
that, well, those words are generated
from background language model, so they
were generated those words like the.
Example.
And if we use maximum likelihood
estimator, note that if all the words
here must be generated from this model,
then.
This model is forced to assign high
probabilities to award like that
because it occurs so frequently here.
Note that in order to reduce its
probability in this model.
We have to have another model which is
this one to help explain the world.
The here and in this case it's not
appropriate to use the background
language model to achieve this goal,
because this model would assign high
probabilities to these common words.
So in this approach, then we assume
this machine that was generated.
These words would work as follows.
We have a source controller here.
Imagine we flip a coin here to decide
what distribution to use with
probability of Lambda.
The coin shows up as head and we're
going to use the background language
model and we can do that simple word
from that model with probability of 1
minus them.
Now will do decide to use the unknown.
Topic model here that we would like to
estimate and we're going to then
generate award here.
If we make this assumption and this
whole thing would be just one model and
we call this mixture model 'cause there
are two distributions that are mixed
together and we actually don't know
when each distribution is used.
So again, think of this whole thing as
one model.
And we can still ask for words, and it
will still give us a word in a random
manner, right?
And of course, which word will show up
would depend on both this distribution
and that distribution.
In addition, it would also depend on
this Lambda, because if you say Lambda
is very high and it's going to always
use the background distribution, you'll
get different words than if you say
lemme's very small, we're going to use
this.
Right, so all these are parameters.
In this model.
And then if you think in this way,
basically we can do exactly the same as
what we did before.
We are going to use maximum likelihood
estimator to adjust this model to
estimate the parameters.
Basically we're going to adjust well
this parameter.
So that we can best explain all the
data.
The difference now is that we are not
asking this model alone to explain
this.
But rather, we're going to ask this
whole model mixture model to explain
the data becauses there has got some
help from the background model.
It doesn't have to assign high
probabilities towards like the.
As a result, it would then assign
higher probabilities to other words
that are common here.
But not having high probability here.
So those will be common here.
I.
And if they are common, they would have
to have high probabilities according to
maximum likelihood estimator.
An if they are rare here.
Right, so if they are rare here.
Then you don't get much help from this
background model.
As a result, this topic model must
assign high probabilities, so the high
probability words according to the
topic model would be those that are
common here, but rare in the
background.
OK, so this is basically a little bit a
IDF waiting here.
But this would allow us to achieve the
effect of removing this top awards that
are meaningless in the feedback.
So mathematically, what we have is to
compute the like hold again local, like
hold of the feedback documents and.
And note that we also have another
parameter Lambda here, but we assume
that the Lambda denotes the noise in
the feedback document.
So we are going to, let's say set this
to a parameter that say 50% of the
words are noise or 9% are noise and
this can be assumed to be fixed if we
assume this is fixed.
Then
We only have these probabilities as
parameters, just like in the simplest
unigram language model.
We have end parameters and is the
number of words.
And then the likelihood function would
look like this.
It's very similar to the likelihood
function local.
I can hold a function we see before,
except that inside the logarithm
there's a some here, and this sum is
becausw.
We consider two distributions.
And which one is used would depend on
Lambda and that's why we have this
form.
But mathematically, this is their
function with theater as unknown
variables, right?
So this is just a function or the other
values are known except for this guy.
So we can then choose this probability
distribution to maximize this locali
code.
The same idea as the maximum, like
Horace made it as a mathematical
problem.
We just we just have to solve this
optimization problem.
We essentially would try all the
theater values and until we find one
that gives this whole thing the maximum
probability.
So it's a well defined math problem.
Once we have done that, will obtain the
serial F that can be there, interpreted
with the original query model to do
feedback.
So here are some examples of the
feedback model learned from a Web
document collection, and we do sudo
feedback.
Are we just use the top ten documents
and we use this mixture model so the
query is airport security?
What we do is we first retrieve 10
documents from the web database.
And this is of course a pseudo
feedback.
I and then we're going to feed that
mixture model to this 10.
Document set.
And these are the words learned using
this approach.
This is the probability of award given
by the feedback model in both cases.
So in both cases you can see the
highest probability words include very
relevant words to the query, so airport
security, for example.
This query words still show up as high
probabilities in each case naturally
becausw they occur frequently in the
top ranked documents, but we also see
beverage, alcohol, bomb, terrorists,
etc.
So these are relevant to this topic and
they if combined with the original
query.
Can help us match more accurately
documents and also they can help us
bring up a documents that only imagine
the some of these other words.
Maybe for example just the airport and
then bomb for example this.
So this is how single feedback works.
Issues that this model really works and
picks up some related words to the
query.
What's also interesting is that if you
look at the two tables here and you
compare them and you see in this case
when Lambda is set to a small value and
we still see some common words here.
And that means.
When we don't use the background more
often, remember Lambda can use the
probability of using the background
model to generate the text.
If we don't rely much on background
model, we still have to use this topic
model to account for the common words,
whereas if we set Lambda to a very high
value, we will use the background model
very often to explain these words.
Then there's no burden on explaining
those common words in the feedback
documents by the topic model.
So as a result of the topic model, here
is very discriminant if it contains all
the relevant words without common
words.
So this can be added to the original
query to achieve feedback.
So to summarize, in this lecture we
have talked about the feedback in
language model approach.
In general, feedback is to learn from
examples.
These examples can be assumed, examples
can be sued, examples like.
Assume that the top ten documents that
are assumed to be random in there could
be based on using fractions like a
feedback based on pixels or implicit
feedback.
We talked about the three major
feedback scenarios, relevance feedback,
sooner feedback, and in principle
feedback.
We talked about how to use Rock You to
do feedback in vector space model and
how to use query model is missing for
feedback in language model and we
briefly talked about the mixture model
and the basic idea.
There are many other methods, for
example, the relevance model is a very
effective model for estimating query
model.
So you can read more about these
methods in the references that listed
at the end of this lecture.
So there are two additional readings
here.
The first one is a book that has a
systematic review and discussion of
language models for information
retrieval and signal.
One is important research paper that's
about relevance based language models,
and it's a very effective way of
computing query model.